et mesdames et messieurs
jamais que quand elle est sortie de la
loge de maquillage et de le styliste
dont on ne savait pas qu'elle était
déguisé en fait parce que c'était une
tenue qui lui bien comment ça va
ravissante jeune coiffeuse mais dit oh
mais c'est bien c'est raccord avec tes
cheveux est ce que vous savez
par contre une chose est sûre c'est que
vous n'avez pas dû souvent tenir à
balayer la première fois vous envoyez un
mail à comme celui ci oui non et vous
savez que j'ai rêvé de vous y la belle
hier soir c'est vrai et depuis que
depuis que je fréquente l'équipe de
touche pas à mon poste je fais des rêves
et cauchemars vers jarbi oued et autres
trucs alors j'ai pas trop envie de vous
en parler mais il ya des photos des fois
qu'ils me viennent comme ça qui me passe
par la tête quand je rêve le soir je
donne ma libido y lit avec nous alors
qui est avec vous à votre avis qui est
derrière ce ces squelettes
c'est jean michel maire
jean michel c'est marrant parce que vous
aussi j'ai rêvé de vous je fais des
rêves hyper bizarre en ce moment j'ai
honte mais je préfère pas vous dire que
je vous ai enfin bon peut-être qu'une
image apparaîtra aux téléspectateurs un
moment ou un autre mais c'était très
basse et
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs nous avons là
c'est la mort c'est thierry mots laurent
thiry parce que
la tête que vous faites là en ce moment
ne bougeait pas c'est exactement la tête
que font les téléspectateurs quand vous
sortez une vanne une relève m
c'est normal j'ai un humour mortels et
néonazis et messieurs regarder il est là
le sauvegarder
[Applaudissements]
les jours où il faut avoir les yeux
rouges il ne les a pas et c'est quand il
est capable c'est aujourd'hui qu'il
fallait avoir l'oeil rouge
elle n'a pas envie de rigoler j'ai je
vais vous sucer comment vous croyez que
je rentrais sur d8
alors nous avons également christophe
carrière
abner mares tué ce matin vous allez voir
ça change pas grand chose
un mélange de jean pierre françois demis
roussos et jacquouille la fripouille un
petit nouveau nous a rejoint
dams et laissez vous aller l'accueillir
comme il se doit lors sa tête vous avez
vous verrez cette année or figurez vous
me direz pas comme ça ils s'appellent
miguel de rennes
[Applaudissements]
il faut l'accepter pour sa première
d'autres déguisée en citrouille et en
femme surtout d'ailleurs vous allez
allez distribué quelques bons bruit je
vais démontrer bienvenus et il est avec
nous pour une raison très simple vous
m'avez tellement pourri sur twitter pour
qu'il soit autour de la table alors
j'avoue l'offre pour halloween
bertrand shenhua lui c'est aux
roubaisiens nous vous vous rappelez sans
abri bon vous n'avez pas peur halloween
tout va bien d'autres on sait qui c'est
qu'elles pensent qu'à la pub deux et on
voyait arriver vous allez voir
[Musique]